fractals are shapes that exist between
Dimensions let me introduce you to one
that exists between zero and one
dimension take a line of length one
divide it into three parts of length 1/3
just keep the two end segments and throw
the rest out so n is equal to 2 now
repeat that process the remaining
fragments are split into three parts of
length 1 over9 keep the two ends of each
and you now have four fragments this
process and you will have infinitely
many points in a line of zero length
it's called the cantour set we can use
this formula to find the dimension of
the Cantor set and it works out to be
0.639 which is indeed between Zer and
one more than a point but less than a
line